Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Sorry, I've been getting so many, like, work messages and, um, like, stuff I have to do right before I stream.
So I have to, like, answer them and be like, oh, okay, I can get that done, like, real quick, just right before.
And I'll just loop one more time to get this done.
Everything.
It's really busy.
Really, really, really busy week this week as well as next week before, like, I think, like, as soon as the birthday stuff is over, like, things are gonna...
cool down a little bit and then get busy again.
But, but, yes, there's a lot of stuff going on behind the scenes right now.
Um, okay, do you guys want that update first or do you want announcement?
Well, not announcement, but more like, um, update.
A different update.
Uh, all right, that update or that update first.
Okay, that update.
Oh, it's not big announcement, guys.
It's not a really big announcement.
It's, it's, it's, it's merch related.
So it's not, it's not that big of an announcement, guys.
Um, okay, I'll do, uh, okay, let me read this.
Uh, uh, okay, I'll do, okay, I'll do that update first.
So I have to read, like, read the thing that I have to say later.
Um, anyway, so, dad update.
So, um, this happened a couple of days ago because I'm, like, spacing out these dad updates.
Um, so, um, so, basically, uh, a few days ago, I found out that dad can experience jealousy.
Because, um, I sat down on a bench and another dog came up to me and, like, jumped onto the bench next to me and sat next to me and was, like, hi.
And I was, like, hello there.
And then, and then, like, you know, like, I mean, I have a dog next to me.
So I was just, like, you know, I'm gonna pet you.
And then that dog was, like, super happy.
He's, like, yippee, pets.
And then, dad saw us.
He, he saw us and then started approaching us.
And he was, like, what the fuck are you doing in front of me?
And he got really mad.
He started, like, barking at us.
He's, like, what are you doing?
It's, like, how fucking dare you touch him in front of me?
He's, like, he was, like, really mad.
And he tried to, obviously, he's, like, really short.
He can't jump.
So, like, he tried to, like, you know, he tried to perch his legs on the bench.
He's, like, let me up!
Let me up!
Because he can't jump on the bench.
And then me and the other dog just, like, licked at him.
I was, like, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that he's, like, this to the other dog.
I'm just, like, what?
What, you can go up to other women and let them pet you, but I can't pet another dog?
Like, what about the quality here?
Why?
I have to watch you go up to other women and let them pet you.
You show your belly to them, but I can't touch another dog.
I...
Um, Petra...
Uh, Petra has said, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I watched your fight against the Godskin Nova.
I just want to say, lol, nice one.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't pet a different dog, apparently.
But yes, he had, um...
That's different, Doki.
Uh, but yes, he...
I found out that he does experience jealousy.
Because no other dog has actually, like, approached me before for, like, pets.
Like, usually the other dogs would just do their own thing.
They don't randomly approach owners.
Like, my dog.
Where dad would literally just, like, walk up to random people and just be like, Pet me!
But, like, this is the first time a dog actually went up to me.
And, like, sat, like, actually jumped onto the bench and sat next to me.
And was like, yay, you want to pet me?
I was like, okay.
Um, but yeah.
Anyway, so that's the dad...
That's the, uh, dad update.
Um, he...
He has finally experienced jealousy.
And he was not happy that I was petting other dogs.
All right!
Announcement time!
So, um, I was just sent in graphics for the birthday merch.
That will be, uh, the birthday concert merch.
Not the actual birthday merch.
Because there will be actual birthday merch.
But, uh, obviously.
Ha ha ha!
Handled by my new distributor.
Uh, so, um...
For those who are wondering, for the actual birthday merch that's coming out next week.
On my birthday.
Not the concert one.
Um, we're gonna have some of the stuff already in, um...
Um, in, uh, the warehouse.
So, some of the things.
If you're ordering, like...
If you're ordering, like, single items.
There will be, like, uh...
Some of them will ship out right away.
Uh, because we do already have some of the items in the warehouse.
Uh, we don't have all the items.
But we have some of them.
Um, but...
So, you're planning ordering the bundles.
You might have to wait, like, maybe, like, a month or two.
But it's already a lot faster than last year.
But, so, I just sent graphics for my concert birthday merch at Anime Expo.
And for those who are wondering, oh, I won't be at Anime Expo, we are planning on doing pre-orders for it after the concert.
But it will be like maybe like two weeks after, one to two weeks after the concert.
So, we are planning on doing pre-orders for it.
But for those who will be going to Anime Expo, I will be showcasing the graphics for it and where to find the booth.
For those who are like wondering, like, oh, where do I get these items and stuff like that.
So, like for those who are planning a trip to Anime Expo, let me grab the graphics real quick and show you guys.
Okay, let's see.
And then let me like copy the map too.
Okay, grabbing, I was literally, they literally sent this to me like two minutes before the stream, like, I'm sorry.
When the stream went live.
They sent this to me when the stream went live.
So, I was like, whoa, gotta grab everything.
So, here is the birthday concert merch.
So, you sort of see there's going to be like tickets, standee, buttons, and a sticker.
So, you know, it's not like that, like, like, because we have to get all of these done, like, within a month.
This was done within a month because, you know, was it in one month or a month and a half?
A little more than a month basically.
So, we have to get a lot of these done very soon so it's not like, obviously, it's not like super big merchandise stuff, but it's still a lot of cute things.
So, it will be at the Noms Cafe booth.
They will have a separate section that's dedicated to, dedicated to Doki Bird.
Me, as in me.
So, they have, like, a separate booth dedicated to me, and we will be selling concert merch.
So, I'll give you guys close-ups.
Yeah, it's on... my concert will be on July 3rd, but the booth will be there for the entire Anime Expo.
So, I'll give you guys, like, close-ups of the illustration.
So, we will have a standee and also a ticket right here.
The reason why we have two... the reason why we have two separate artwork is because we didn't know if we were going to get any of these artwork done in time.
So, I commissioned two different artists to see if we could get them done in time.
And luckily, both of them got them done in time.
So, because they were like, oh, you know, I don't know if I could get it done in time.
But luckily, we got both of the artwork done in time.
So, this one is buttons and stickers as well.
So, you can get dad button and me button and then a giant sticker.
I don't know how big the sticker is.
It might not be that big.
So, these will be merchandise at Anime Expo that you could get at my booth.
And this will be dedicated to the, um, birthday merch.
So, you can... if you guys want, you know, a more boorish outfit or a more girly outfit.
We have two types of do... we have two doki flavors.
So we can have two Doki flavors.
So the more girly Doki or the more boyish Doki.
So yeah, so these are the two different types of... not two, sorry.
Two different types of artworks you can get for your merch.
And the booth will be right here.
I know it's a little hard to see, but it's right there.
So, uh, right over here.
So it's next to... it's basically close to the Square Enix booth.
So it will be at booth 3724.
The... what is it called?
I don't fucking know.
The self-hall?
I think this is a self-hall.
It's right here.
Let me... right over here.
If you see Square Enix, you'll find the booth.
It's right there.
So if you are at Anime Expo, um, you will be able to grab these there.
We were planning... I know some of you guys were like, oh, is it gonna be exclusive merch?
We are planning on putting the merch on pre-order, but it will be after the...
It'll be after the con... it'll be after Anime Expo.
So it'll be maybe, like, a month... like, two... two weeks to a month, basically.
Um, for when you can get the merch for, uh, for the Anime Expo concert merch.
So these are, like, the concert merch, basically.
Um, there is gonna be, like, actual birthday birthday merch.
Uh, but that's the concert merch on itself.
Um, anything else?
Oh, yes, if you are at Anime Expo and you were never able to get the, uh, discontinued Doki merch, we are planning on selling some extra stock.
Uh, we have a couple of extra stock of the old merch.
So the Retro Edition and the Lunar New Year.
We're not planning on putting this back up on the online store, but they do have, because, uh, Nam's Cafe was actually, uh, helping me with distributing for, uh, my old merch.
Um, um, and helped me a bit with distributing a little bit of the old merch, uh, when, um, things were getting really delayed and everything.
So they do have some of the, uh, retro...
They do have, like, some remaining stock of the Retro Edition and the Lunar New Year merchandise.
So if you're at Anime Expo and you never were able to get any of this, these merch, merchandise, you can, you will be able to get them at Anime Expo.
Uh, so they will be selling the remaining stock of this there as well.
So, anything else?
Anything else?
Uh, I do also have a collab going with Nam's Cafe as well.
So there's a lot of merch there.
There's a lot of stuff.
So if you're at Anime Expo, I also have a collaboration with them.
So, um, so there's gonna be, like, little chibi stuff as well.
So you need to be wanting, like, more chibi stuff, chibi charms.
There's, like, charms, uh, a print as well.
And, uh, because they are also helping me with distribute...
They are helping me with selling my, uh, Anime Expo stuff.
So, um, I am doing a collaboration with them as well, since they are helping me out with selling, um, my Anime Expo concert merch, as well as, like, being there as a booth for me.
Um, because, like, you know, without them, I wouldn't even have, like, a booth there.
So, and it's, like, they...
It's, like, a whole...
They're dedicating, like, half of their booth to my stuff, too.
So it was really nice of them to do that.
So I, um, I was, like, yeah, we can do a collaboration as well at Anime Expo.
So, um, there's gonna be...
Anime Expo, if you're, like, looking at these things, I believe you can only get them at Anime Expo, this collaboration.
So, or, like, wherever conventions that Nam's Cafe is at.
So, um, you'll be able to grab these at, not, uh, at the Anime Expo booth as well.
So there's several collaboration in works.
Oh, well, several.
One collaboration.
There's, uh, there's one collaboration as well.
So, yes, that is all the updates regarding, uh, Anime Expo.
Um, the concert is at July 3rd at, I believe...
Oh, my gosh.
I think it was, like, 1 p.m.
or 2 p.m.
Um, I think so.
So, if you guys didn't know, there is a con...
I will be doing a 1 p.m.
I will be doing a Anime Expo, uh, 3D concert for, uh, on July 3rd.
Uh, but that doesn't mean July 4th.
There isn't also anything...
Uh, there's also something very special planned on July 4th.
And on July 3rd, I'll be doing a countdown stream where I'll be announcing something very, very special related to my birthday stream.
So, uh, uh, on July 3rd, uh, I will have a stream at night.
I think it'll be, like, at 11 p.m.
PST where I will be doing a countdown stream.
And, um, and, uh, I'll be doing a countdown stream.
And we will be announcing something very special, uh, that will lead up to my birthday.
So...
And there will be another announcement on my birthday at the end of the stream.
That's why I've been so busy.
There's so many announcements.
There's...
There's so many!
It's so hard to keep track.
So, there is a special announcement on the countdown stream and also a very special announcement at the end of my actual birthday stream.
And also, next week, there's a...
Finally, we're collabing with Chibi-Doki next week.
We're gonna play Roblox Doors.
Sorry, I just dumped everything onto you guys.
I...
Chibi-Doki and I finally have arranged a collab for next week.
So, the two Doki's are finally gonna do something.
It was very hard to organize, by the way, because we're both very, very busy people.
I think this collab has been in the works for, like, months now because we're always so fucking busy.
And then, like, because of that, we, like, don't respond to each other.
Like, when we're really busy.
Okay, sometimes it's me.
It's, like, both of us.
So, like, um...
At one point, like, we didn't talk to each other for, like, a month because, like, we were both so busy while we're in the middle of trying to organize a collab.
Because, like, I remember, it was, like...
Okay, so, like, recently...
The most recent one was basically, it was like, Oh, yeah, are you free next week?
And then I got sick.
And I was like, I'm sorry, I can't do it.
I'm, like, really sick right now.
I was like, I'm, like, super...
And then he's like, it's all right.
We can...
Oh, and then she was like, oh, I have to go travel next week.
But, like, I could do it, like, when I get back.
I was like, yeah, we could do that.
And then I replied.
And then, like, after she got back, she's like, oh, yeah, when you want to do it?
And I was like, I'm sorry.
I need to take a break right now.
I'm so burnt out.
And my brain is so fried.
And then she's like, oh, it's all right.
And I was like, sorry, I have to travel for this concert.
So, it was fucking...
We were all, like...
Like, there was always so many fucking delays leading up to this collab.
But now, confirmed.
Oh, yeah.
And then...
We were supposed to collab this week.
And then we were actually about to, like, announce...
Like, I was about to put it on my schedule.
It was supposed to be this week, too.
On Saturday.
And then we were...
I was about to put it on my schedule.
And then Saba announced that she was debuting on Saturday.
And then I was like, oh, Chibi.
It was like, oh, Chibi.
We got to reschedule.
I don't know what time that collab...
What time her debut is.
But, like, we can't do it on Saturday.
So, then it got pushed to next week.
Because it was just...
All of it just didn't fall in line.
Nothing.
And it was before Saba announced her debut time.
Because, like, I think she announced when she's debuting.
Like, today.
Or was it...
It was Iron Trader yesterday.
But, like, you know, when we were...
We had the collab planned on Saturday.
Like, we were talking about it on Monday.
We were like...
Oh, yeah.
On Sunday.
We were like, oh, yeah.
Let's, like, put the collab on Saturday.
And then...
And then we didn't know what time.
And then, like, you know, I checked.
We were like, yes, let's do it.
Yeah.
Yeah, all right.
Saturday.
And then...
And then, like...
And then I looked at my schedule.
And I was like, wait.
Isn't, like, Saba debuting this week?
What day was it?
And I looked at it.
I was like, oh, fuck.
Okay.
I was like, sorry, Chibi.
We gotta reschedule again.
Because we can't do it this Saturday.
And Chibi was busy the entire week.
She was busy on, like, Thursday.
Um, Thursday, Friday, and Friday.
So then I was just like, oh, fuck it.
We'll push it to next week.
Oh,
fuck it.
Oh, fuck it.
I was like, oh, fuck it.
Okay.
Next week, then.
Next week, Saturday.
Nothing is gonna be in our way this time.
Nothing.
We will be okay this time.
Um, so, um, yeah, sorry.
Wednesday, Thursday.
Wednesday, Thursday, and Friday, she was busy.
So, like, basically, like, we, the whole week, this week, it was just, like, impossible for us.
And that's why!
If the collab was pushed to next week.
Um, next, next week, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But are you going to use the Chibi-Doki so you can be Chibi-Doki and Chibi-Doki?
No, so then, so people can distinguish between the Doki.
One will be Chibi, and then the other one will be regular-sized Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, so, finally, the collab won't be rescheduled.
Finally!
Um, yes, it's big Doki and little Doki.
Anyway, it's Elder Ring time.
All right, so I played around with some more fixes to see if I could...
I don't know, it was for some fucker reason.
That world was so fucked up in Elder Ring.
That was, like, I don't know why.
Maybe it was because I had maximum grass.
But, like...
That shit, like, stuttered, like, crazy compared...
Because, like, the other playthroughs, it was...
There was still some stuttering, but it wasn't that bad.
For some fucking reason, Lava Mane was so fucked up.
All right, I did save my sound settings for Halo this time.
So, we should be good to go.
Wait, I didn't.
JK.
I did not.
But that's okay.
Like, I can do...
I can save it now.
Because I haven't adjusted my sound system yet.
All right.
And then, I think...
Let me double check.
Uh...
Okay.
Eleven.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
There we go.
Gotta make sure the sound is all correct.
All right.
I don't know if I fixed it.
But, like, maybe it'll be a little better.
Maybe.
Okay.
Let's...
Let's make sure...
I'm just gonna make sure that...
Uh...
I'm just changing the graphics real quick.
You're like, I can't see anything!
It's okay.
You're not missing out much.
I'm literally just on the settings, guys.
Okay.
Advance.
It's on high.
Okay.
Good.
All right.
Everything seems to be okay.
And I put grass on medium.
Uh...
Justin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You should be croaky during your collab with Chibi-Doki.
So you can both be the same size.
Thank you for the super chat, Justin.
Thank you.
It's actually crazy the amount of stuff I have to, like, play around with for Elden Ring.
So, I'm on borderless window now.
So, um...
How the fuck are my messages are still there?
I was...
So...
I'm on borderless window.
So, I don't know if that will work.
But, like, that was apparently one of the fixes.
All right.
Apparently...
Guys, okay.
There's, like, a little silver war going on in my chat.
And, like, in the Dragoon community about whether or not she'll be doing this side quest.
Like, guys are saying...
Some of you guys are saying she's never gonna use any of these items in the chat.
So, is that true, guys?
Am I picking up items that I will never use?
Or am I actually picking up items that...
That I am never going to equip, guys?
Is that true?
Yes, I don't care.
Do the side...
Who cares if she uses them or not?
What do you mean?
Who cares?
I care!
What do you mean?
What's the point?
The side quest and the rewards aren't worth it!
They are essential.
You get a legendary...
Yes, but am I gonna use it as a thing?
I already got a fucking 0.05...
0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 1% item drop on my first try.
And I'm not even using that item.
Alright.
How about this, guys?
We'll do...
Put the story in lore.
Guys, we already killed Patches.
What other...
We already killed him.
I think the story part is already shut down.
Okay.
Okay, but it's the poison katana.
Better than my current katana.
Guys.
Besides...
Patcher...
Or Anton!
Patcher Esu!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's content.
And people like the heckin' cute characters.
Besides Moonvale or Rivers of Blood, which are not side quest rewards.
We probably won't change weapons this run.
Okay.
Say goodbye to that red spot.
But I can use two katanas.
Wait!
I can use two katanas?
Okay.
Wait.
Now you're speaking my language, guys.
Guys.
Okay.
Now you're speaking my language.
What...
Will my two katanas do more damage?
Versus one katana...
Oh yeah.
My death counter.
Why did...
The important thing is...
Will my two katanas...
Do more damage...
Than my one katana?
Yes?
Alright.
See?
You should have started with that.
Guys.
If you guys started with...
You can get two katanas.
We'd be down there already.
Alright.
It's like here somewhere.
I don't know.
Somewhere here.
Didn't expect dragon.
Okay.
Loco.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Doki.
For being a little goofy goober.
We all love and enjoy.
Guys.
What do you mean it's our fault that I'm...
You didn't mention two katanas.
All you did was like...
There's loot.
What kind of loot?
I need details.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Me and my horse...
Is having a rough time.
No down ahead.
Okay.
Then why am I here?
What the fuck?
Oh, is it here?
Try jumping up?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, maybe...
Yeah, maybe this would help me.
I think I need a nightlight.
Here.
Okay.
This has to be it.
What's this?
Oh, no horses allowed.
If only...
I had a horse.
Professor Oak is like...
This is not the time and place for this right now.
I got Professor Oak'd.
Hey.
Apparently, uh...
There is a dragon here.
What?
It's so empty.
Oh, Zyko.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Naga.
Kaiba.
The longest katana.
Poison katana.
Oh, wait.
There is River of Blood.
The best bleed katana.
Oh my god.
There's so many katanas.
How many katanas do I need?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No secret ahead.
Wait.
Why am I here?
Oh.
Okay.
JK.
I didn't see below me.
Oh.
There's a dragon down here.
Isn't it?
There is a dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Toki.
If you play the DLC right at the beginning, you can get the cool dragon katana.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys.
You did say...
What was it?
Seven bosses?
Guys.
If you want me to...
Do the DLC...
That concert was very expensive.
You had a crowd fun for that.
You had a crowd fun for the DLC.
Don't worry.
Down ahead.
Therefore, try jumping.
Okay.
Beware.
Oh wait.
Is that pit?
Yeah.
That's a fucking pit right there.
All right.
It's either we crowd fun or 900k.
And I'll continue Elden Ring.
900k subscribers.
I'll continue Elden Ring.
Next thing.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're playing Elden Ring for charity here.
At that time, it was for the...
What was it?
The mental health charity.
Now, I'm the charity.
To progress past seven story bosses, you need to help me.
I'm the charity.
Okay.
We go straight?
Is this actually where...
Okay.
Wait.
I think I actually fixed the stutters, guys.
I say maybe...
Wait.
I think I fixed it.
God fucking damn it.
I've only did that before.
I've only...
Zekra, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Can I also contribute...
Funding for DLC shenanigans.
Frozen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's this?
Try lightning.
Alright, it's too late.
Betrayal, no treasure ahead.
Oh shit, I feel it.
I feel like these guys are gonna fucking push me off the clip.
We're in a Doki charity.
Thank you for the super chat, Mike.
You'll understand why.
Later on when...
After the concert, you'll understand why.
Why we need a crowd fund for more Elden Ring.
You'll understand.
Alright.
Oh shit, that's not why I want Waste God.
Am I like...
Heading the...
What the fuck?
How did you miss three times?
Couldn't be me.
You'll understand.
Something incredible ahead?
Wait, how did all these guys die?
My first Akasupa to contribute.
Zekra, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Oh, there's a...
No, that's for...
That's not an important item, right?
Wait, these guys are so easy to kill.
I don't understand.
Toki is suffering charity.
Thank you for the...
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
How did you miss that?
Thank you for the Akasupa airport.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let's grab this guy.
I feel like I don't...
I swear to...
Whoa.
Did I get it?
What pushed he...
Guys, he...
He jumped off first.
I didn't do it.
I'm not a murderer.
He jumped off first.
Okay.
No snow horse ahead.
Liar ahead.
Am I like over leveled for this area?
I was like, Why did all these people die?
I have to be over leveled.
Or were they pushed off?
Oh, they were just pushed off?
Asim, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm doing...
I'm doing my part.
Jumping require...
That has to be a lie.
Lie.
Poor...
Okay, guys.
Guys.
All right.
Wait, where is it?
Necessary item ahead.
All right.
Make sure when you're here, make sure to upload this.
Downvote this.
And then upload this.
Uh-oh.
AHHHHHHHHH!
Where am I?
There!
I don't like...
Oh!
I'm different!
I don't know how...
I just tried to be unclear.
I jumped off the cliff.
I...
Okay, I want more Elden right now.
Look, thank you for the super chat.
I don't know how to get back...
I...
Where is it?
I... I don't know where it is.
Okay, I think it's... I'm gonna explain that again.
Okay, I'm back.
I'm back.
Okay, let me figure out how to get there again.
It's so long.
I think it was here.
Okay.
Okay, I remember.
I'm pretty sure.
Carbo is real.
I accidentally pressed circle.
I'm so sad.
I jump.
No!
My sauce!
Why did I jump?
Oh!
Okay, I remember.
I'll get back though.
Oh!
Why did I jump?
I forgot the plan!
I thought I could make it!
Oh my god, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki is a true leader.
Oh my god, please.
I'm already having a bad day, Mr. Bear.
I'm sorry!
Okay.
Alright.
I remember.
I'll get there.
Oh my item.
My runes!
My beautiful runes!
What did I do to deserve it?
I can't possibly think of what I did to deserve this.
I...
I... I don't understand.
What could I have possibly done to deserve this?
Okay.
How the fuck do I...
Oh, it's right here.
The worst part is that I made it through, like, all the bullshit here.
And then I died to, like, the dumbest thing.
Alright.
Uh, terminated.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I, too, would like to contribute to this crowdfund, as we need more Elder Ring Souls content from Doki.
Also, Doki, watch where you land.
Oh my god.
This is right here.
I almost forgot how to traverse this place.
Okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm so healthy.
Alright.
Everything is okay.
I made it.
I'm back.
Guys, I'm back where I started.
Alright, here we go.
All for this stupid fucking side quest.
Okay.
Alright.
We gotta go this way.
Get over here.
I'm mad.
I'm mad now.
Get your ass over here.
Oh my god.
Okay, now I understand how you can die here.
Now I understand.
Okay.
I understand that.
I might get knocked off.
Alright.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
I actually fixed it.
Why did I not do this sooner?
Okay, anyway.
As I was saying, make sure to upload this.
Uh...
No!
Oh my god!
I almost did it again!
Okay.
And then, upload this.
I almost did it again.
I know.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're okay.
Everything is okay.
I keep pressing circle accidentally.
Alright.
Seek left and then precious item.
Here.
Okay.
Oh, there is the precious item.
Oh, you didn't die.
Hahaha.
She just doesn't learn.
I...
Look, I did...
I'm learning now.
I'm learning now, chat.
I figured it out.
Try horseback battle.
Oh, can I...
Use my great...
Use my horse now?
That's what I didn't expect.
Behold summoning...
Oh, what?
Okay.
Uh...
No, I can't.
Wait, what?
Why did I say horseback battle?
I'm confused.
Do I live?
Okay, I live.
Okay.
I'm always worried about that.
Those deaths don't count, guys.
They don't count.
I didn't die, but...
The environment does not count, guys.
The environment means nothing.
The environment deaths are not real.
Oh my God.
We'll get rid of him first.
Oh my god.
Guys, okay, actually, I'm just gonna lean...
I'm not just... Oh, thank god there's a grace.
Oh, thank god, okay.
I'm... I got worried.
Gravity... Gravity does not count.
Okay, like, when you trip and fall, you don't go to the hospital.
Okay, I'm here now.
Oh my god, wait, he has fucking armor.
Okay.
Oh my god!
What's this?
Oh shit!
There we go, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh shit, wait, that's not fine.
There's something to do with these spirits.
I don't like it.
Okay, we gotta get rid of these guys though.
Alright.
I'm like a little... a little scared.
Don't worry.
That arrow in my head, it just missed my brain.
So we're fine.
You know like those like...
Like, you know like sometimes bullets basically like get past all your internal organs?
That's what happened to me.
It literally just missed my brain.
Like it's crazy.
Oh my god, I hit every fucking wall?!
Holy shit!
Okay, we're okay.
I somehow hit every single wall there.
Wait, where am I?
What the fuck?!
Oh, I'm here.
Okay, is this part of the side quest?!
Yeah, I'm like in the...
Okay, yes.
Okay, I got a worry there.
I was like, I don't know if this is...
I couldn't tell.
Alright, let's grab this guy.
Let's just backstab him.
Here we go.
Yeah, that's on Neo.
Ooh!
Wait, I need all of these.
Nice.
Neo is just chilling.
Alright.
Let's get rid of him.
Bye!
Yay!
Why is he fighting this guy?
Yeah.
Get out of here!
I'm faster.
Yeah.
Alright.
I think this is a good place.
This is a good place for this.
I'm like 13.
Alright.
This is my message of praise section.
Right here, with a view.
I think it's a nice...
Nice place for it.
I like kill everything here.
Alright.
Let me go this way.
A very lovely place.
I hope that's...
I hope that's the...
I hope that was from...
From where I just put the...
Whoa!
Oh my god.
That better be where I just put my last message.
That better be it.
I better go back there and see...
Like...
One...
Upvote on that message of praise.
Okay.
We need this for jellyfish.
Nice.
Alright.
Then we'll kill this guy.
Oh my god.
Look.
No...
Actual...
No more studies.
Oh my god.
It only took five parts.
Wait...
It actually...
Guys, it only took me five parts to figure that out.
To fix this.
So apparently...
Elder Ring has this weird thing...
Where like...
You can't play Elder Ring on full screen...
If you have a monitor...
That goes above 60 hertz.
Which is...
Fucking crazy.
Like...
That's...
Like you have to play it...
On...
Borderless window.
Because like...
It will stutter because of it.
Yeah.
So I have to...
I had to play on...
Borderless window.
Uh...
Because like...
I...
My hertz was like...
Higher than the game itself.
So...
Uh...
So like...
So that's what was causing the studies.
Because the...
Elden Ring can't...
Deal with...
Like any...
Can't deal with monitors...
Higher than...
Oh my god.
I should have killed you first.
Uh...
That's higher than...
60.
Which is fucking weird.
That's so weird.
Yeah.
So that's why...
So now we don't stutter anymore.
This is not for Volcano Matt!
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, these fuckers.
Me...
I'm for mimicry?
Alright, at least we're at...
We're at some fucking random boss, I guess.
What the fuck?
Wait, that's...
Who is he?
Oh my god!
Who are you?
What the fuck?
She has a whip!
Hit!
Alright.
What the fuck is this guy?
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm trying like figure out her like pattern, but she...
Okay, I didn't need a fig...
Alright, jump.
Yes.
You're so close.
Okay.
I...
Whoa.
Okay.
You're like not that scary actually.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I am so sorry for saying that.
You're...
You are so scary.
Oh my god.
You're right.
Maybe she was scary.
The ego check.
Okay.
There she is.
Ah!
That's where I was before.
We might need to find some churches here.
What the fuck?
Oh, is that a trap?
Oop, that's funny.
Oh, yeah, that was a trap.
Big fan of don't have more fun at the park next time, Igor Samoyan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, let's get these guys out of the way.
All right.
Okay.
Wait, there's something here.
Oh, I missed an item here.
Yeah, I definitely wish I knew that earlier on about the borderless window thing.
Then we didn't have to deal with all those stutters.
I wasn't too intrusive, guys.
I hope those stutters weren't too intrusive in the earlier playthroughs.
Down item.
First off, behind.
Oh, there it is.
All right, it wasn't that bad.
That's good.
Now it's, uh...
But now, now it's easier.
All right.
It's time.
Wait.
Offer joy.
Weakest boss ahead?
This boss is a joke?
Okay, guys, I don't...
Pathetic sword ahead!
Guys, I don't know.
I feel like I may or may not be getting gaslit, too.
It's all right.
All right.
Hello.
Hello?
Is it this guy?
Wait, that's it?
Wait, it's me.
Oh, shit!
Are you saying he's weak because he's me?
Oh, that's what you meant!
Oh, I'm so dumb!
It's me!
That's how you're like!
Don't worry, Doki.
She's so weak.
Hey!
He is strong, all right?
She will be the strongest opponent I've ever faced, guys!
Oh, my God!
Why are you using your hands?
Oh, she is me!
She...
Bro, she doesn't even know what to do!
She's just as confused as me!
You heard a Doko bird?
This is a bird Doki.
Oh, my God!
She doesn't even know my patterns!
Wait, no, she does know my patterns!
She's...
He actually used his lucky fist!
Because that's what I've done before!
I...
She is...
She is me!
Boki Dirt!
Oh, my God!
It's Boki Dirt!
The one time I lock it in!
The one time Boki Dirt locks it in!
Oh, my God!
Okay, that's not fair!
My Oshi Boki Dirt!
It's bad!
Oh, my God!
Look!
She's rolling so much!
I do that, too!
Look!
She's panic rolling!
Oh, my God!
She can heal!
Message of Praise!
Guys, how many times can I heal, guys?
I need to know!
Oh, my God!
What?
Dude!
He's like, what do I use?
You always get so confused!
What do I use?
That's me, too!
Me, too, Boki Dirt!
Sometimes, I don't know what I'm doing, either!
Okay, nice!
Whoa!
Which one is the real Doki Dirt?
I can't tell!
They're both!
Which one is her?
Same.
Oh, my God!
She's panic rolling and everything!
She does jump attacks like me!
It's okay, I'll kill her by...
with pure poison.
The real Boki Dirt way.
There we go, we did it!
Yeah!
Yay!
We did it!
So easy!
We won!
We defeated Boki Dirt!
Alright, here we go.
I guess we go this way.
Oh, Grace!
Nice!
How do I raise a message for the other one?
Cora!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Workshop!
The best way to be a double ganger!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
Oh, wait.
I think I have enough runes, actually, for this.
How much do I need?
I can...
Oh, I can just use that.
I think it was like...
Yeah.
5k should be enough.
Uh, Brewer!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Is that fight murder or suicide?
Um, do we do dexterity?
Right?
Dexterity.
Alright.
And then what do we do after dexterity, guys?
The weakest doki had to...
Had to 2v1 the other doki.
Shake my head!
Time for horse!
Try horse.
Wait, isn't that, like, where...
Wait, this is familiar.
Why horse?
Still no tree.
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
Yeah!
Bird.
Why horse?
Okay, I'm gonna do horse.
Cause I'm scared.
Cause everybody's like, Use horse, doki!
Use horse!
I'm like, why?
What's over there?
Just deers.
Nothing over here.
Oh, I remember this area.
Death ahead.
Okay, I guess we don't go this area.
Oh.
Where...
Just a big area?
I feel like I've been here.
Is there, like, areas I haven't explored here?
Chat?
Like, is there some place I haven't gone to yet?
I've been to a lot of places.
I've already explored a lot of this area.
Oh, hey, there's a guy here.
Hello.
Lord of blood, your eminence.
I beg you, grant me a seat at a table of destiny.
Long live the Mogwen dynasty.
Gorgeous view.
Oh, it is pretty.
That is really beautiful.
He just says the same thing.
Where the fuck do I go?
Do I have to light this up?
Oh, my God.
Do I have to?
They have...
Oh, my God.
They have dogs.
Oh, wait.
No, they're deers.
They're not that threatening.
Do I have to, like, light those up, chat?
Can he seize me?
Or is he just playing music?
Oh, my God.
I forgot how strong these guys are.
But it's okay.
Oh, that's right.
Invincible iframes, bitch.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he doesn't care.
Okay, maybe I should...
Oh, my God.
No, no, no!
No!
I had my mana potions out!
I accidentally had my mana potions out.
Oh!
I...
Oh, my God.
Not the mana potions.
God damn it.
Okay, that was awkward.
I can't believe, like, I didn't even get to, like...
Where I actually had to...
Oh, my God.
That's fine.
Let me light this up.
Okay.
Let's leave.
I'm trying to, like, figure out where to go.
Can I kill her?
No more music.
No more music for you!
That's right!
Oh, shit!
I hate music!
I'm like, oh!
I...
My God!
She's so strong!
Giant woman.
She, like, pimp slapped me.
Holy shit!
Oh, my God.
Her friends...
She's like, how dare you hit my Oshi!
That's right.
Your Oshi graduated.
That's right!
See ya!
Wait.
Bye!
Oh, fuck.
There's another one here.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Alright.
No sentries.
Okay.
There's a fire, right?
I can just go behind.
That's fine.
Fine.
I'll just do a...
I'll just do a drive-by.
Bye.
That works.
How many are there?
How many flames do I have to get?
Hey, guys.
Guys, how many are there, anyway?
For this puzzle?
Six?!
Jesus Christ.
Okay, we got three.
We got three, though.
Okay.
Three more.
Gotta figure out where the last three are.
Alright.
We got that.
We got this one here.
Oh my god.
This wasn't even the lava fucking puzzle.
I'm so sad.
I don't even know how...
I don't even know how to do this god damn stupid lava puzzle.
Alright.
We gotta find two more.
Wish I knew where the lava puzzle was.
Oh, wait.
One more?
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's right here.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I thought I could iframe that.
I thought I could iframe it.
I...
Now I can.
That's right!
Double iframe!
Oh!
Okay.
We did it.
We got the double iframe too.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He came for me!
Oh my god!
That's okay.
Oh, it's not okay.
It's okay.
I don't think he knows I'm here.
I think he got tired.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think he knew I was behind.
If...
If he went home...
He got tired.
Then that's fine with me.
I'm okay with that.
No object from an instinct, guys.
Okay, where do I go with these?
Alright.
We go up here?
Is it that?
No, that's where everybody... No, that's where I'd sneak in.
Place with the torches?
Hey, that's my jellyfish.
Wait, you're still alive?
Oh wait, no, this is like... That's where all the wild jellyfishes are.
Oh my god, that's where I kidnapped my child.
Okay.
Yeah, but I wanna grab this item.
Alright.
That's where I kidnapped her.
Oh, it's here.
Oh my god, it's another one of these fucking deers?
Oh my god, it's Spirit Away, the sequel.
Where's the Grace, though?
Apparently, is there Grace nearby?
How the fuck is the other Grace?
I'm gonna finish the job.
I killed Bambi's mom.
I'm gonna kill Bambi's dad now.
It's South?
Okay.
Let's figure this out.
Oh, this is not here.
Is it South or West, guys?
Is it here?
Near the wolves?
South, West?
Here?
Where?
Nothing here.
Oh, there's an item here.
Nets.
Item.
Somewhere here.
Yeah, we need this, actually.
Okay, it's not here.
Wait, were these wolves chasing me?
They're like, Boss, we couldn't get him!
He was too fast!
Okay, it's the other way.
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Alright, let's get this.
Secret tier?
There?
Okay.
I feel like...
I feel like that's a bait.
That feels so fucking bait-y.
Alright, let's go for...
Let's go for the deer.
Alright.
Killing the deer.
The sequel.
Electric tube boogaloo.
Alright, here I am.
Alright.
Time to kill you again!
I killed your wife!
I'm back at it again!
Only messages here?
Oh, I can.
Alright, let's see.
I did it.
That's right.
I'm already congratulating future Doki.
You go, future Doki.
You fucking did it!
How is this deer gonna do?
Fucking die like his...
Like his wife?
Look at that.
Look at him.
He barely does nothing!
Okay, I need to not lock in for this one though.
This deer is at...
The deer...
Locking in is just not it.
What?
What he said?
I bet I did it.
Wait, is he just...
Is he just respawning?
What the fuck?
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
He came back to life!
He's slowly walking towards me.
Eh, loser.
Look at him.
He wanted to like get a rematch already.
Stupid.
He's so weak.
Look at how weak you are!
Look at you!
Go die again!
Born again.
Yeah, he did a fucking...
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Wait.
What's going on with this guy?
Oh my god!
Wait, my jellyfish!
Wait!
Jellyfish!
How did you lose all that HP?
Okay, that's how.
That's how.
Okay, that's how he did it.
He lost.
Okay, I understand now.
I understand.
Where did all the HP go, buddy?
Wait, what?
Evil Gear?
What's going on?
Wait, what?!
My god!
He rejects?!
Oh my god!
I needed a...
Oh, that is so bullshit.
Oh my god!
He has appraisals too!
Oh no!
Wait!
I got...
Oh my god, this is not fair.
Wait, he has appraisals!
Oh my god!
How do I kill something that can be appraisals!
How do I kill something that can be appraised?!
Not fair!
No way!
Oh, Jokey, it's not fair now, is it?
When you're on the other side!
It's not... Oh, now it's not fair!
Oh god.
There's only room for one content creator here, guys!
Oh my god.
Please don't heal again.
Please.
No, that's not fair!
Oh no.
Bro, he keeps dying!
That message was appraised.
Haha, tables have dirt.
Wait, what?
Okay, that was a roll.
That was a roll.
Bro, this guy just dodges every time, too.
At least I'm not playing like a pussy!
Guys!
I take- NOOOOO!
Okay.
Okay, I didn't think he would do that much damage.
I really- I didn't think so about that.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, now- Now I know what he does, guys.
Now I know.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, Kevin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, now that I know.
Now that I know.
Oh.
Okay, I need to grab my runes first.
I know now.
Oh my god, you literally just lived.
Okay.
Okay, I know now.
Oh fucking hell.
Oh my god.
You guys- Please get poisoned.
Oh, come on!
Okay.
No.
No!
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Get over here.
I'm not letting you message appraise.
If I learn anything from my own build, I just gotta make sure you don't get message appraise.
Gotta make sure- Don't you fucking- Don't you fucking dare get message appraise!
That's fucker!
This fucker.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's so- Come on.
Oh shit!
I didn't see my HP.
The message appraise.
What's the- It's the battle of the streamers right now!
It's the battle of the streamers right now!
It's the battle of the fucking streamers!
Who has more fans?
Fuck you!
Who the fuck has more fans right now?
The battle of the century!
The message appraise.
I will appraise more than you!
Oh my god, I miss.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Holy shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
The dragoons will win!
Fuck you, nature!
The humans- Animals are going in danger, not dragoons!
Alright, where is he?
Get in there.
Come on!
Stop running away like a little bitch!
Are you serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, no!
That's right, message appraise this!
Fuck you!
Our fandom won!
That's right.
Remember this, dragoons.
We won the fandom war.
It's like the Saja boys versus the Huntricks.
We won!
That's right!
Victory chug!
Let's go!
Fandom of- This is why we're fandom of the year, guys!
This is why!
That's right!
You're all gonna go in danger!
You're gonna chop down all your trees now!
That's right!
This is Team Edward versus Jacob!
And I won!
That's right!
Message appraise this!
Alright!
We did it!
Uh...
But fuck, guys!
We did- This wasn't even the- God!
The worst part is that this wasn't even the fucking- The fucking side quest too, for lava matter!
Alright!
Let's go- Oh yeah, we got it!
Let's go- Wait, can I level up here?
Okay, I can!
Nice!
Alright, guys!
What do we do after- Do we still do Dexterity?
What do we do after that?
Chat!
What do we do?
Arcane?
Is it worth it now?
Cause I know some people were like, don't do arcane yet!
River of blood?
Am I supposed to get the river of blood katana?
Okay, it's okay to level up.
Okay, I'll do 11 then.
Alright, I'll get it later.
Okay.
Alright, let's go level up our little jellyfish.
Nevermind.
Let's not, I guess.
Does that mean I shouldn't level up my katana anymore?
So I can sh- Save?
Uh...
So I can save for, uh...
Save up for like, level up for my other katanas?
Okay.
Alright, so like...
I don't know what to do for this side quest.
Like...
The red dot is gone.
Where do I go?
There used to be a red mark here.
It's gone.
Unless I already explored it.
I go to this one now?
There used to be a red marker right here.
But it's gone now.
So I guess I'll go here?
I guess I'll go there.
There used to be a second red mark there.
I guess it's gone now.
This is where I met my first maiden.
Alright.
Okay, and then we go here.
I need to make sure not to jump when I do that.
Cause like, jumping apparently, like, raises my fall damage.
Okay.
Okay, it's somewhere here.
Where is it?
There?
Oh, am I ready?
Okay.
Usually, no.
Okay, I'm not.
But like...
It's fine.
This one?
Alright.
Hello.
Oh my god.
I'm evil now.
Oh, hey.
Hello.
I'm not...
I'm friendly.
Shit!
Oh, shit!
Oh, I forgot to go to Grace!
I forgot...
I forgot to get Grace!
Oh, shit!
Guys, guys.
We have to rely on...
Oh, my god.
Oh, am I the invader or is he invading me at this point?
Am I...
Holy shit!
You bitch.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, I get less heals if I invade.
I was gonna say, wasn't I...
I thought I had Grace!
Like...
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my god.
This guy does so much.
Okay.
That's...
At least I know I'm faster there.
Guys, I'm pretty fucked up.
Wait!
You can't hear me!
I'm just saying!
Oh, my god.
Do I get to keep my Grace at least?
I died.
Okay.
We...
Okay, now I know.
Okay, I gotta get my shit back.
My one build...
No!
He took away my...
Wait, where's my...
Wait, where's my shit?
Wait, where's my Grace?
Wait!
He took my Grace!
Oh, I didn't lose them?
Thank god.
Oh, thank god.
I thought I lost him.
Okay.
Good to know.
Alright.
Fucker.
Oh, my god.
It's not fair.
You have...
Grass by your side.
Guys.
I thought you said this guy was easy.
Oh, my god.
I hate him.
Okay, guys.
I think I need more churches.
Maybe.
He is.
Guys.
I definitely need more churches.
I hate him.
Oh, my god.
My appraisal heals does more heals.
That's...
My flask!
It's so fucked up!
Okay, guys.
We gotta find churches after this.
We gotta find...
We gotta find churches after this!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go find a church.
Let's see.
I need religion.
Oh, my god.
The fact that my appraisal does more healing than my fucking flask.
That's so awkward.
Wait.
My grace is gone.
My runes are...
You liars!
I lost my runes!
You guys said I don't lose runes!
You liars!
Oh, is...
Was it, like, outside?
Was it, like, here?
Oh, when I died, they leave it...
Oh, my god.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, I didn't realize they were right here.
I thought it meant I...
Okay, where is the church near me?
Where's the closest church, guys?
Hey.
No, wait.
There's something here.
Oh, my god.
Those were my zero runes.
Those were...
Okay.
All right.
Where is it?
Go south?
Okay.
I just go south?
All right.
Okay.
What should I get?
How many plus flashs should I have?
Guys.
Okay.
Wait.
Is it easier if I just teleport?
Can I just teleport here?
Even further?
Here?
Further?
How much further can I go?
Wait.
Oh.
Here.
Here?
Oh, like here?
We're here.
That way?
That's it.
I'm...
Churches in Elden Ring.
Fuck you guys.
We're never gonna...
You guys are never gonna guide me to the right area.
You guys...
Fuck it.
I don't...
You guys are never gonna guide me to the right area.
All right.
Okay.
Here.
Wait.
Is it here?
Is there more to this map?
Is there more?
Wait.
Here?
All the way here?
You are ungrateful.
Wait.
There's...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's get over there.
I didn't realize we're missing that much of the map.
All right.
Let's figure this out.
Okay.
Let's get rid of these two.
We gotta go here.
Wait.
What number is that?
That's two.
Where the fuck is one?
Oh, there's...
One over here.
The fuck is four?
Where are my markers?
Oh, there is one.
Okay.
Here we go.
All right.
Now, we should be fine.
It should be, like, this way.
I didn't realize I was missing, like, half this map.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, hey.
There's stuff.
There's a merchant here.
Hello.
Here we go.
Oh.
There you have me.
Only worsens.
Until the floodgates burst.
Unleashing eternal torment.
The strength of...
Oh, he has a good katana?
Magnificent.
Oh, my god.
That's the Roshi right there.
It's no surprise that drug and communion...
You must not forget the old super...
Oh.
It's a long sword.
If we're trying to attack...
Wait.
Do I have to kill him?
Is it worth it?
This is like...
Oh, you can do the quest.
Okay.
I was about to...
I was like...
Is it worth it, guys?
Is it...
Guys.
I was about to do it.
I was...
I was this...
I was ready.
No hesitation.
I was like...
Wait.
Gear?
Okay.
He almost died there.
Yeah.
It was...
This close to dying.
She's right behind me, isn't she?
He he.
What are they all looking at?
What are they all looking at there?
They're scouting for stuff.
Alright.
I'll enter.
What is this?
Oh.
Wait.
I remember this guy from Night Ring.
Oh.
Wait a minute.
I don't think I was supposed to be.
Oh my god.
I actually like...
Oh, hey.
These...
Oh.
I'm so over level for this.
I...
I may or may not be over level.
It's just maybe.
Oh shit!
If he gets bleed, maybe not!
It's fine.
I just wanna make sure I don't get bleed.
Okay.
Nevermind.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Nevermind.
No, please don't bleed me!
Please!
Okay.
We just gotta wait.
We just gotta chill out.
Okay.
But I'm worried about the bleed though.
It's fine.
I did it.
Yay!
Message was appraised.
Oh my god!
This guy only gave me 1900?
That was how over level I was.
Holy shit!
Okay.
I was definitely not...
I was definitely way too strong for that fight.
Yeah.
I probably could've tanked that shit.
Nope.
I probably could've.
Uh...
They all live here.
Nice.
Uh...
For later, Doki.
Go to the outskirts, Grace, and follow the road, Narve, East.
You can find a church with sacred tear and a cool item.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
The fuck is that?
The outskirts...
What?
I don't know where that is.
What is this?
Yeah.
Can you give us a super chat thingy?
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I don't know if I could live through that, though.
There has to be...
Oh, there is a parkour.
There.
Alright.
Nice.
I just have to get through this bridge.
That should be easy enough.
Shit!
Okay.
I need to...
Kill this guy.
Okay.
Just in case.
Alright, that is a key.
Okay, and then...
Follow this road?
Weeping Peninsula?
Oh, hey!
Are you okay there?
Hello?
Is somebody there?
That's me!
Might I bend your ear for a moment, please?
Here.
My name is Irina.
I've escaped from Castle Morn to the south.
A new wife.
A new maiden.
I can't be sure what it is.
My eyesight's been weak since birth, you see.
But I swear I heard frightful howling from all over.
Kofi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Press Y, then X.
Oh, shit!
That's really helpful.
Thank you again.
The super chat.
Okay.
Oh, he's definitely dead, dead.
I'm sorry, man.
Won't live in my place?
Because you're...
You're technically an orphan now?
Oh, I'll take care of you.
Oh, there's the grace.
There she...
There it is.
Alright.
We gotta figure out where...
Where...
To get this church.
No, guys.
Her dad's dead.
We don't need to find...
Her dad.
He's dead.
Oh, she has a quest so I keep talking to her?
I...
I fear for father's loss.
The servants are full wrath.
Filled with hatred for every one of us.
They've since come for every one of the companions I escaped with.
Oh, shit.
The curse.
I fear it's no different at Castle Morn.
Please.
I implore you.
Would you mind taking a letter to my father?
At the castle.
My soul wishes that he escape.
Even if his honor should be the price.
Please.
I just want him to be safe.
Alright.
Chair.
Whoa!
That's a cool head here.
Alright.
I got your letter.
Deliver it to my father.
Who remains in the castle.
If you please.
Okay, cool.
Don't worry, man.
I can just lie to her, right?
And be like, I did it.
How would she know?
No strong foe ahead?
Oh, it's that guy?
What the fuck?
How can she write?
She's blind.
That's fucked up.
So fucked up.
Yeah, but I'll just come back, like, after, like, two to three business days.
And be like, I delivered a letter.
I did it.
Oh, wait.
We need this after we...
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, there's a map here.
Actually, let's grab the map first.
Okay, uh...
We'll grab the map first before we go anywhere.
Hello.
I'm here for the map.
Map time!
Map time, map time.
Here's the map.
Fa-ba-da-da-dum.
Nice.
Do you know where...
Whoa!
Okay, that guy's not a fan.
Anyway, do you...
Do you know where the...
Oh my God.
I can't even open the map.
The fuck is the next church?
I was trying to get the map!
What is this?
Oh, nice.
What's that even coming from?
Oh, that's where he was coming from.
Holy fuck.
I was like, who's shooting that?
Oh, there he is.
Oh.
Okay, I can't Skyrim this.
Man.
Can't Skyrim, so I kill.
Alright.
Up this way.
You know they gave Jeff Jordans?
That's, like, great.
There's a new Jeff emote in Marvel Rivals and they gave him some Jordans.
We don't need Grace.
We just need to find a stupid church.
Oh, wait.
Item.
Oh my god.
It's a rat... rat bush.
The fuck is this church?
I'm here to have my sins forgiven.
Ignore it?
Okay.
Ah.
Down here?
Oh, I found a new map.
What looks like a church?
Oh my...
I don't even know what looks like a church here.
Go west.
On the other side?
What?
Oh my god.
There's a bridge.
Like... here?
Look for building shaped spots.
Isn't this a church?
No, it's not, right?
I can't tell.
Oh.
What the fuck?
What?
Is this a church too?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh hey, I found a grace.
Okay, fuck that.
I'm pulling up this map.
Wait, no.
There is a church somewhere here.
It's what?
Church...
Kalu Baptismal Church?
Where the fuck is that?
Guys!
There was a church right here!
Oh my god.
No, it says Kalu Baptismal Church.
It's like somewhere here.
Oh my...
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is that?
Guys!
What the...
You're trying to take me to like Nadia.
There's a church right there.
Oh!
Oh yeah, I forgot.
Fucking West bullshit.
Oh yeah!
Okay.
Let's head over to the other church.
I should make this, right?
I don't know.
There's a lot of depth here.
I don't feel like I could.
Can I make this?
There's a lot of people dying here.
Let me be here.
Okay, yeah I can.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Can I do a flip?
Alright.
Let's get it all the way up there.
Okay.
Alright.
And then...
Then we'll have...
Then we should have enough for an upgrade.
Alright.
Come on, churchy.
We gotta have more than plus two.
Because we are not surviving the invasion.
Alright, nice.
Oh, and there's a grace here too.
Nice.
I think I have...
I think I'm pretty sure I already have.
Yeah, I knew it.
Yeah.
I was sure I had enough right now.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, it's my thing.
Okay.
And then one more church is like...
Here.
Right?
That's the church, right?
Yeah, that's the last church.
Guys, I pulled up the Google Maps.
Siri!
Where are all the churches?
I have committed too much sin.
Why is there a two?
Oh.
Thank God.
For Google Maps.
Alright.
We just gotta head that way.
Wait, there's a turtle up there.
What the fuck?
What's that?
Okay, that looks like a fucking...
A moving island.
Right there.
That giant turtle?
Yeah, that looks like a fucking...
Turtle house.
Like, you know like the...
The old wives' tale with the...
Um...
What was it?
The...
The Russian witch?
What was her name?
There you go.
Yeah, the Russian witch that lives in the...
The house with chicken legs.
Yeah, Baba Yaga.
That shit looks like Baba Yaga over there.
Don't say her name!
Alright, nice.
Alright, well now we're plus four.
What's going on there?
Is she looking at me?
Oh, look at that.
Is that a boss?
Oh, if I kill her, can I like explore that house?
Alright, we got all the churches here.
What other church are we missing now?
Sorta?
Oh, it won't hurt me?
I'm gonna hurt these guys.
Heh heh heh heh heh.
Heh heh heh heh.
That's right, you're so weak.
Oh shit!
Alright, let's get over.
And say hi.
They had no head.
I had to get rid of them.
For the sake of humanity.
What can I...
How do I get in?
Let me in!
There's barnacles on his feet.
Oh!
I see it.
Oh, I see it.
Wait, those aren't barnacles.
They're fucking human skulls.
What the fuck?
How many fucking humans have you crushed?
Ew.
That was easy.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was not easy.
The skull barnacles.
Okay.
We're almost done.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I don't know how the fuck that other foot got here.
I have a feeling this is not important too.
Okay.
I think that's all of the skull barnacles.
At this period.
Oh, I did it!
Wait, is he happy now?
What?!
Oh, I thought he was gonna crush me.
Oh, he's happy.
This is a filler episode.
We're in a filler episode right now.
Alright.
Get up there.
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
Hello.
Oh.
Oh, so it was useless.
The fuck am I gonna do with this?
What do I do?
Oh.
Oh, I could eat a...
Oh, I could eat the souls!
You're right!
Wait.
Should I do like...
Should I do his?
And then I eat the other souls?
Yeah, I could just get free souls.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum,
yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yeah, but I'm gonna use katana.
None of them have katana.
Oh, save for later?
Okay.
I'll be back, little guy.
I'll be back.
Yeah, but do the boss weapons have katanas though?
Wait.
Is there loot?
Yeah, if I'm not gonna use the boss weapons...
Yum, yum, yum.
It's like that guy...
Like that gif of that guy that just steals...
That doing something and stuffs it in his mouth.
That's me.
Oh, there is late game?
Oh.
Okay.
Why is it a strong katana?
That's the question.
Alright, I think I'm ready now.
Alright, it's time to do this again.
Okay.
We're trying...
We're doing this again.
If the most difficult boss in the game gives you a mid katana...
Guys, you're not really selling this to me.
I might go...
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Guys.
Okay.
It's like here.
You're making this more...
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Time.
Alright.
He's gonna fuck me up again.
But like...
I'll try one more time.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I know I can get like...
At least one down there.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Never...
Wow.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Jesus.
I'm trying to lock in.
Stupid.
Oh my god.
He has iframes too.
Fucker.
Holy shit.
It's not fair.
He's also spamming.
Only I should be allowed.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
I know he did that.
Oh my god.
He's faster.
It's not fair.
He's so much faster than me.
He's so much faster.
It's not fair.
You're so fast!
Yes!
Ah!
Okay, I'm dead.
Oh...
Okay.
I need to like know his pattern.
Okay, but like, not yet.
Okay, I sort of figured it out.
Maybe.
I didn't know his pattern, guys.
I didn't know.
Okay, but like, I almost figured it out.
Where the fuck did my roots drop?
Why did it drop so far?
Okay.
We go back.
Our invasion doesn't count, guys.
I died in his world.
So it doesn't count.
I can't use a heavy attack for my magic stuff.
It's like... It's like two...
Oh my god, it's not fair.
I was trying to do my magic, but he, like, got to me before I could.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, got it.
I should heal up, actually.
Same.
I like... We both at the same thought.
Okay.
Okay, I am faster.
That's good to know.
Well, now I know.
Oh my god, really?
Oh, they split!
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay.
I got too confident.
There we go.
We figured it out.
Oh!
I did it.
Look at that.
So easy.
The green.
I saw bleed.
I was like, oh my god, this is my time to shine!
Okay, nice.
I got his armor.
Alright.
Is this armor that I'll actually use?
Chat.
Wait.
Now what?
I did all the red spot.
Is it actually better than this?
But is it better than what I have right now?
I don't know.
Is it this?
I don't have this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's see if we can make this work.
Keep up the helmet?
Okay.
Alright.
We keep the helmet and then we'll...
Is this fat a rose or a normal rose?
I can't tell.
I dropped the bow, but the bow has been so good to me.
Okay, that's normal.
Okay, what if...
Okay, what can I...
Oh yeah, that's definitely fat rose.
Wait, did I have like light rose earlier?
Did I have light rose earlier?
Or was it...
Oh, I had medium.
Oh yeah, I just had normal.
Okay.
I couldn't tell.
Okay, then I can put my arrows back then.
Alright, I killed him.
Did you read the letter left for you?
That is the task the Volcano Manor desires you enact.
You will be called...
Elden bling.
Skysike, thank you for the...
Uh, super chat, thank you, thank you.
If you are loathed to hunt your own kin, so be it.
But you must leave this house at once.
This is a war against the Erdtree.
We have no place for the meek.
Nor the luxury of keeping...
But I already did it.
I killed him.
Oh my god, I forgot that one.
I forgot that was my face.
You've completed your task.
I am pleased.
Yeah, look at me.
Yeah, I did.
You are a recusant truth.
That's you guys.
There it goes, that's you.
I am a member of the Volcano Manor.
This is your reward.
As promised.
Hey, I got magma shot.
Never forget that the recusant fights to tread the path of the champion.
The way is tainted.
But for this very reason, it is the true path.
Is she working for the devil now?
Kevin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Now you are a recusant truth.
And a full-fledged member of the Volcano Manor.
I am pleased.
To have you on our side.
Put the helmet back on, bro.
Wait, I already did.
Wait, do I not have another mission?
Is that it?
That's it?
Oh, is there another?
Oh, there is.
Wait, no, there isn't.
Where's that table?
Oh, it's in a different room.
Oh, is it in this room?
Oh, that guy?
What, Alexa said no to?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Uh, at the Atlas Plateau.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Where's that?
What the fuck is that?
Guys, we need to find this map.
Okay, let's find this map first.
Alright.
I need to get the map for this.
I need to figure out where the fuck I am.
What the fuck is that guy here?
Can I, like, backstab him?
Guys, I shouldn't have engaged.
I shouldn't have engaged.
Oh my god.
I don't know why I engaged in him.
Get me out of here.
Wait, that's just a cliff.
Oh my god, they fucking killed so many of the other giants.
What the fuck?
What's that over there?
What is that?
What?
Okay, fuck this.
I'm...
Give me this.
And then, let me try and find the...
Fuck that shit.
I gotta do this.
Wait, I have a heavy attack on the horse?
Whoops.
Oh my god, not the fingers.
Alright, Matt found.
Grace found.
Because I'm still learning.
No one told her?
Okay, now we have plus five.
Okay, now we gotta figure out...
Where the fuck is that?
Wait, there's a red here.
Where the fuck do I get here?
Did I get here from the cave?
What the fuck do I get there?
Did I get there from this cave?
Oh my god, where's the exit?
What the fuck do I get there?
Oh, there's the exit.
Okay.
Can I?
The ruins?
Here?
Guys, this is a whole filler episode.
We're never gonna...
We're actually on our filler episode.
Alright.
We gotta go this way.
The tree?
This side?
Go to that giant ass tree?
Or run to this mark?
I'm just gonna run here.
Or what?
Can I get it from here?
Alright.
Oh, we'll just go straight.
That seems like a bad guy.
Yep.
What's over there?
Wait, there's a dungeon here.
Okay, we're having a filler episode.
We'll be in our filler episode.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
A filler episode in the filler episode.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, I could've jumped off there.
Alright, what's this?
Cracked crystal?
I don't know.
A lot of cracked crystals here.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I have piercing.
What's he trying to do?
Oh, he's trying to light the dynamite?
Why fuck do I do a cracked crystal?
I mean, they seem to be friendly so far.
Tear the head?
Oh, nice.
I'm scared.
There's dynamite next to me.
Oh my god.
That's one.
There's dynamite next to me.
I'm scared.
He followed me?!
Guys, I don't like this filler episode anymore.
Guys, I'm gonna leave.
I don't like this filler episode.
I'll come back later.
Guys, I'll come back later.
Just...
Not the right time.
Not...
This game is very scary.
We'll be back.
Wait, there's something here.
Let's see here.
Are you serious?
Oh, wait.
I can...
Wait, I can fix this.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
What
the fuck?
Oh, he's trying to think there...
Oh my god.
I'm fucking up here.
Oh my god, I didn't think there was actually a platform here.
Okay, that was a leap of faith.
I did not think there was an actual platform on that side.
All right.
Nice.
Never punished.
All right,
I'll do this way.
What the fuck did I put on my mark?
Where did it go?
Wait, it's somewhere here.
Is it above me?
Wait, what?
Wait...
Oh, there it is!
Okay, I found it.
Okay.
All right.
Time to invade this guy's world.
Where is he coming from?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, he has arrows.
That's a nerd.
That nerd.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, nerd with blood!
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, this nerd is fast.
Oh, shit!
Nice, we both thought the same thing.
Backing up though.
Oh my god, we both got each other.
Oh!
Get out of here, nerd!
Oh my god, you fucker.
That's fuckin' right!
I beat first!
Ah!
I'm faster!
Haha, that's fuckin' right!
That's right, I'm faster!
Let's go!
Oh!
I'm so much faster!
That's right!
Using range weapons!
Yeah, I got...
I got stuff.
What if I can like...
Is there any grace nearby up here?
Guys, is there grace here?
No?
Okay, I'll leave.
Here, oh wait, there's like...
Is this like where I'm supposed...
...for the next area?
Where's the castle?
This one?
Oh, here.
Oh, there's the castle!
There it is!
Oh, I see it!
It's right over there!
Oh, okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank god!
I dropped down and I...
Actual fear.
When I dropped down, I legitimately thought I was...
I went to my death.
Alright, nice.
Safe.
Alright, lady, I did your...
I did your second assassination.
I did the thing, ma'am.
I did your stupid little assassination thing.
I see you've performed another task.
That's me!
Here is your usual reward.
Please, take it.
Oh!
That's a cute sword.
Now, perhaps the time has come to tell you...
The true ruler of this manor.
Lord Reichard.
The erd tree blessed the tarnished with grace.
But it was all too meagre in the face of the enormity of their task.
Oh, that's the poison katana?
Oh, it's over then!
Squabbling for crumbs.
Like the shard bearers vying for power in the wake of the shattering.
Our lord, indignant, has refused to scurry about, fighting over what miserly scraps they allow us.
If the erd tree, and indeed the very gods, would debase us so, then we are willing to raise the banner of resistance, even if it means heresy.
We at the volcano manor, under lord Reichard, have sworn no rest until it is done.
If you follow this heroic path, one day the lord will see you.
The lord's visits with our champions are always a spectacle.
It cannot come a day too soon.
All right, it's time to kill your lord.
If you follow this heroic path...
Okay, now I can kill him, right?
All right, let's grab...
Where is it?
Is this one?
Oh, there it is.
And I have two.
Slashy, slashy!
All right, and then...
Uh, oh wait, was it Y, X?
Oh,
there it is, all right.
All right, now it's time to upgrade my blade!
Okay, now I can...
Now I can kill the boss, right?
No way.
I should have it.
Lay out your arm.
Yeah, I know I have enough for this one.
Okay.
I know a guy!
Don't worry!
What guy was it?
I forgot, it's been so long.
It's been so long since we saw him.
We know a guy, chat!
Where was it?
Where did he live?
I forgot!
The South Lake?
The fuck is the South Lake?
Which guy sells the stone?
We know him!
Oh, by the entrance?
Where's that?
What is that?
The Lake Merchant?
Is it this guy?
Is this the guy that we know?
Could be him.
Oh, there he is!
I told you, I knew a guy!
Hello.
I told you guys I knew a guy.
Okay, we don't have enough though.
Okay.
Fuck!
Okay, where are the mines?
Where are the mines?
Guys, we don't have enough.
We need one more.
Wait, I can't use katanas versus the...
Why not?
Way northeastern.
Guys, not that mine.
Anything but that mine.
Oh, I can buy them at the round table?
All right.
This one?
Guys, I...
Which barrel barrel barrel should I...
Offer this one?
Oh.
This is awkward.
I literally just need one more.
I need one more stone.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh my god, I did.
I do need one more.
I need level one smithing stone.
But I don't know which mine it is.
Okay, I'm pretty sure that mine does not have the level one smithing stone that we need.
It seems a little too hard.
Wait, should we get that?
Should we get this one?
What's that do?
Oh.
Oh, it's an extra here.
Okay.
Now we gotta figure out which mine this is.
Where's the mine?
Where is it?
East of Magic Academy.
Here?
In the lake.
Oh, in the lake?
Oh, here.
Here.
East.
Oh, that's west.
Here.
Yeah.
Okay.
This should be...
Is this one?
The random dot?
Wait, this is level two.
Guys, we need a level one.
We need level one stones, guys.
We need...
We need level one.
Oh, here.
Where?
This one.
Okay.
We figured it out.
Okay, now I have to figure out how to get down.
Down.
Get downstairs.
Okay.
Uh, here.
Now we figured it out.
This way.
Guys, we figured it out.
We're doing it.
We're learning.
We're Elden ringing, guys.
We're doing it.
This is exactly why I brought up Google Maps.
All right.
Grab it this way.
Oh my god.
It's so far.
It's so fucking far.
Why can't you...
Why can't I level up my horse?
I should be allowed to level him up.
Okay, we should be almost there.
What are these guys doing?
They're just chilling.
Oh hey, there's jellyfish.
Hello, little jellyfish.
Oh, there's evil jellyfish too.
Hello, evil jellyfish.
Oh, they're all evil!
They're all...
Okay, they're all evil.
All right.
This should be it.
Oh, I hear a bell.
Why is there a bell here?
Hello, guys.
What you guys doing?
Ping-bong.
Oh wait, I...
I'm not there yet.
Whoops.
Sorry, I got distracted.
I heard a giant bell.
Oh, it's another one of these things!
Oh!
We don't need that yet though.
Yeah, but we don't need that.
Okay, the mines should be somewhere here.
I'm yearning for the mines right now.
I yearn for the mines!
The filler episode was in my filler episode.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
All right.
My filler within filler.
Okay, here I'll go.
All right, let's make sure we have everything we need.
All right, let's go!
Filler attack.
What's he doing?
What the fuck is that?
What is that guy doing?
All right.
How do I...
Oh my god, he's so fucking...
Like...
Guys, how do I use my second one?
He didn't sleep.
Or is it because he's made of rocks?
Is that why?
Oh my god, he tried to nerd his way out.
L1 and L2?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, L1 and L2 uses both.
Okay, that's good to know.
I need, like, the yellow rocks.
These aren't yellow.
Do they hurt me?
My god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, what is he doing?
All right, there we go.
Wait, is this heavy roll?
Oh my god, this is heavy roll.
Okay, let's just...
Let's use one for now.
And then...
Yeah, let's...
Let's just use one for now.
Do I have dead stain?
Oh, but there's something over here.
Can I make that?
I don't know if I can.
Can I make that jump?
Can I even make that?
Slow and steady, Doki.
Slow and steady.
No.
Wait, how did he die?
Okay, that's not him.
Okay.
He's a little special.
He's our special little guy.
I did it.
Coming in hot.
On your left.
Okay.
All right, let's go.
Let's go back.
I'm the special little guy.
Oh my god.
I'm not getting that.
That's not worth it.
It's absolutely not worth it.
It's not...
Unless...
Oh, I'm gonna be too!
Fuck!
Okay, it's fine.
That's fine.
It's 4,000.
We don't need 4,000.
It's fine.
I don't need that.
Thanks, guys.
Wow, guys.
You think I need a sprint jump for that?
I'm not...
We're not going...
Which one?
What did I miss?
Oh, there is one.
You're right.
All right, we got it.
God, we found two, but we need a level one.
I haven't seen level ones yet.
Get
him out of the way through.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, fuck!
Oh my god!
I got ganged.
Ganged up on.
Gang violence is not a joke, guys.
Jesus!
Okay.
I didn't think that was gonna happen, but okay.
All right, that's fine.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna brute force that.
No, I wanted to get this guy!
Oh, thank god.
Oh, thank god he stumbled.
God damn it.
I need level one!
Where are the level ones?
Oh, I didn't see...
Oh, I didn't see drop loot.
Somber smithing stone.
Oh no, I'm not using the poison katana right now.
I'm using the regular one.
Oh, I'll get it later?
All right.
Oh my god, they're all level threes.
All right, we go this way.
Longest filler episode.
Okay, this way.
Whoops.
Actually set my elevator back...
back up.
Guys, we haven't seen a story boss in like...
I think two years now.
We gotta kill this guy.
And I hope that...
Oh my god, I keep thinking he's gonna like...
drop me or some shit.
Nice.
He knows I'm here.
Please don't set magic.
Oh my god.
Oh god, thank god.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was so scary.
I thought he was gonna fucking send me off the...
the tank.
Okay.
Oh thank god.
I'm okay.
I live.
My death was exaggerated.
Wait, you're so scared of a nerd.
Jokey.
Okay, I am next to a cliff.
There is a reason why I'm scared.
If I wasn't next to a fucking cliff, I would be fine.
Okay, grab this.
Okay, into that tunnel.
How far away is this boss?
You wear it, right?
That guy?
I got...
Oh, that guy!
Oh, wait.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, I may be over leveled for this area.
Oh, there we go.
We did it.
We got something.
Okay.
Okay, I'm over leveled.
Okay, get out of here.
Yeah, I think so.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
These guys again?
There you go.
Use magic?
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God!
They meant that right!
He meant his right!
Gravity was discovered by Isaac Newton.
You are scared of a nerd.
Thank you for the super chat, Kevin.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but who's dead right now?
That's right.
You're king of the nerds is dead now.
Yeah, this is a never-ending filler episode.
That's fine.
Oh, my God!
I, like, turned to my right!
Holy shit!
Oh, my God!
I did not expect that!
Holy shit!
Where did he come from?
Where the fuck did this guy come from?
Oh, my God!
It was not fun!
Where the fuck is this man came from?
He's here right behind me, isn't he?
Who we got?
Okay, we got him killed before he could do anything.
He's here right behind me, guys.
We got Smithing Stone.
Holy shit, there's so many stones in this one area.
Hello?
Oh, nice item.
Oh, there's a stone here.
Don't they be mad?
Oh, they are.
Guys, I think they were mad.
I think they were mad.
Guys, they were definitely mad.
What was that?
All right.
Yeah, but I feel like they don't have any in here.
Yeah, see, they don't have, like, any yellow ones here.
Yeah.
I don't know why they weren't so happy.
It took them, like, so long to grab those rocks.
And then he came over there and just yanked it out.
Why would they be so mad?
Mad.
First off here.
And so I was like, you can grab it without fighting.
I was like, really?
See, this is why I have trust issues.
All right, this way.
Oh, there's the boss.
We foe ahead, just in case.
Just in case.
Head?
What's this guy?
I don't have enough magic.
Oh my god.
What?
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
Okay, I don't know how it is that.
Okay.
Jellyfish.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, now he's breakable.
Nice.
Okay.
That's good.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's not good.
Get out of here.
Get shatted.
That's okay, right.
Easy.
I did it.
Yippee.
Is there any extra stuff here?
All right, nice.
That's right.
Backshot for days.
Now I have the stone.
Okay.
Okay, I should have enough now.
Okay, first, let's upgrade our katana first.
Okay, let's upgrade.
All right.
Oh wait, I have this.
Wait, I should upgrade this first.
Yeah.
All right.
I'll upgrade that first.
Okay, and then...
Then I'll grab this.
Back over in our mat town.
All right.
And I should have enough for this.
Yeah.
And then I need more smithing stone one.
All right.
Let's go.
Ever since I got my beach episode, it's been filler since.
We've been in an eternal Elden Ring filler episode.
Yeah.
What's this?
Oh, here it is.
I need like, what?
Four?
How many do I need?
Six?
I don't remember.
All right.
Hello.
I'm here to upgrade my katana.
All right.
Oh, I have enough for this.
Oh, now I need smithing stone three.
Okay, I don't have that.
I don't have that.
All right.
But that's enough.
That should be enough now.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
I forgot what the our main quest.
Now.
Now we can beat up the other boss.
Okay.
Oh, I needed souls.
Oh, I just needed souls.
Oh my God.
I'm so out of...
Okay.
This isn't the area I have to go anyway.
That's fine.
It's fine.
I have more souls here.
All right.
Back to the round table.
I got lost.
All right.
I made that...
That ain't mean.
Okay.
Now.
Now we're done.
All right.
Now.
We gotta kill the guy.
But first off, apparently there's another letter.
One last letter and then I kill the guy.
Okay.
That's heavy.
Let's get that.
Let's fix that.
Okay.
Now.
It should be fine.
There we go.
All right.
Is there any more letters?
Or no?
Or is that the last one?
Oh wait.
There's no letter.
All right.
Back to him.
Again?
So, you've blooded your sword in the hunt.
Then I shall introduce myself once more.
Banal.
A recusant.
Just like you.
Recusants have particular battle arts.
Styled to our methods of slaughter.
Why not add some to your repertoire?
Okay.
What does he do?
Oh, I don't need that.
Bye.
Uh.
Where's my...
What's that?
Fuck.
Yeah, no.
All right.
Now.
Now it's time to kill him.
For real now.
All right.
There we go.
Is it time?
It's time, right?
Now it's time.
I'm coming in.
Oh no.
Wait.
No!
Keep accidentally pressing the wrong button.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god!
All right.
Where the fuck is my stu...
Can I upgrade this?
Can I...
Can I upgrade?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I...
Oh my god!
It said there's lava!
Stupid fucking snake!
Stupid snake!
I upgraded my katana just for you!
I said it's just for the stupid snake!
Oh my god, of course.
Okay.
Get out of here!
Castle
for free!
Okay.
Get out!
I'm gonna pay your bill!
Oh fuck!
Okay, maybe you can live here a little longer.
Oh, bye.
It's fine.
You can live here a little longer if you want.
There you go.
He's dead.
He's looking...
Wait, he's not dead?!
Okay, I was gonna sit.
What the fuck do I do?
Okay, this is a phase two.
There's no way.
There...
Oh my god.
I knew it.
I knew there was a phase two.
I...
I fucking knew it!
How far did it go down all the way?
I understand your anger, but you didn't have to call me stupid repeatedly.
Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Snake.
I fucking knew it.
I knew there was a phase two.
I was like, why is there...
Why is the head...
Why is there not one HP?
I'm sorry, I'm sticking with the super chat.
Oh, that's gross.
Oh my god.
That's pretty fucking gross.
Look.
Like, that's like his innards and everything.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
That was like arms and a snake.
Oh my god.
How do I kill you?
How do I?
Oh my god.
Please, dad.
I'm fucking freaking out right now.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god.
I'm like getting hit by everything right now.
I'm actually getting hit by everything.
Because I'm so confused.
I'm so confused.
I'm worried that like...
I'm so confused guys.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
No, please.
I can't focus.
I can't fuck stop.
What do you want?
I don't know what you want.
It's not even feeding time.
Okay.
Is it worth upgrading this?
Is it worth upgrading this story?
Welcome to the Auris dimension.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Kevin, thank you, thank you.
Laugh me, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Now we can devour the gods together.
Oh my god!
And then he walked away!
He walked away.
He actually walked away.
I can't.
I can't with my dog.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
He had... I'm so... I'm... I'm... I... I... I... I... I'm gonna use the bat too.
I'm so mad.
He walked away!
I'm back.
I'm okay.
I can't...
Cosmic, coyote, snake, many, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
No, you don't understand.
I was... I... I could!
I... Oh!
Guys, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
He fucking walked away.
I am some fucking.
All right, here we go.
I was doing so well, too.
Here I am.
Oh my god, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh fuck, that's not fine!
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god.
Am I safe?
I think I am.
Oh, I'm not safe!
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the stupid fire.
Oh my god, the stupid lava!
I got lava.
Okay, thank god.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Oh my god!
Stupid fucking lava!
Guys, please, I...
Okay, I do.
No, I don't.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm like trying to figure this out.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, not the lava.
Not the goddam...
Lava!
No!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Okay... Lava chicken... I don't think he likes Minecraft.
Guys I don't think he likes Minecraft guys!
I don't think he likes Minecraft!
You're the Meinungatus There's a nooooh
WHERE AM I?
G&J FISH, GO!
DIDN'T EVEN SEE WHAT I TREAT And FIGURE OUT WHERE THE FUX I AM?!
Okay.
Oh my god, does this ever stop?
Does this ever stop?
Oh my god!
She's alive!
Oh god, no, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
Guys, a message of praise, please!
Message of praise!
No!
They were so close!
Us!
No humble combo!
I got combos!
It's so hard!
Oh my god!
I can't...
Okay.
Oh!
Make reset.
Because someone would be proud of the amount of orange being shown here.
Okay, now...
Now I accidentally drank the flask.
For your...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
It's doing so well, too.
My god.
My one.
I need this.
My zero.
Ruins.
Thank god for that.
Get out of here!
Shit.
Oh shit!
Nice.
I feel like I'm gonna die by lava any moment.
Okay.
No!
Oh thank god!
Oh!
Please!
Oh thank god!
I was scared.
Okay, that was scary.
Okay.
That was a little too close.
That was a little...
Guys, I chose it!
Okay, there we go.
Holy shit.
Oh!
We did it!
We lived!
Let's be getting like two hits.
I don't know why.
Thank god.
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Okay, I need to back up a little.
Alright.
I healed.
Come on!
Get out of here!
Yeah!
That's right!
That's not me.
That's...
Honestly, I deserve that.
I fucking deserve that so much.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Where am I?
Where...
Welcome to hell!
Holy shit.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Welcome to
hell...
I'm okay.
There's just...
A little bit of a flesh wound Just a... just a little bit.
Just... just a minor flesh wound, everybody.
Oh!
Ow!
Ow, many!
Oh my god!
How many is there?
I'm living by a thread right now!
My... my death was greatly exaggerated.
Ah!
Oh my god!
Power of 70 hours!
Holy shit!
I should not be alive!
Oh, I should not be alive right now!
We did it!
Oh!
That's right!
No together for you!
That's fuck the power of Doki and the dragoons!
Let's let it go!
I should not be alive right now!
You have a snake?
I have 40 health bars!
Okay, what do we...
Okay, what do we do?
Oh my god!
Laughing, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
No one will keep me captive!
A serpent never dies!
Kevin, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Now you know you can't take credit for that!
The appraisals won that battle!
Zyko, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
We appraised this together!
Saber, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki probably...
Where am I?
Why am I here?
How am I still alive?
Okay, we'll do...
Holy shit!
That is five levels worth of...
Oh my...
Did we just go all the way to 25?
For endurance?
Together, my dragon!
Thank you for the super chat state!
Thank you, thank you!
Space, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you state!
Got a 25 hit combo on you!
What do I do two?
Two on endurance?
And then...
What else do I need?
What else do I need after that?
Got it!
Good job chat!
We beat the boss!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh, laughing!
Thank you for the super chat!
Okay, dexterity?
And then we can put...
Two on dexterity...
And then what after that?
What do we do after that?
An arcane?
And then we'll put one more on arcane.
Here you go!
Holy fuck!
That's fucking crazy!
That was a fucking crazy boss fight we had!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Get this...
God damn...
Sword out of here!
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay, now I can use the stupid fucking katana that I built!
This isn't streamer luck!
This is streamer earned!
Ruben!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
MrBrokenFile!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Well done, Doki!
You make it look...
So easy with the ADL bars!
We did it together!
Ha ha ha ha!
Thank god, chat!
We spent so long upgrading our two swords!
I did it!
It's true then!
Now I'm your lord!
You defeated our lord!
No!
I must thank you!
Our lord was yet weak!
That's right!
I'm your new lord now!
Defeat is not the end!
Our lord is immortal!
I'm the new daddy of this fucking hell!
Exactly!
Stronger!
Until then...
I must stay the path...
And do my part!
Wait, what?
What do you mean, go back?
What even is that area that fucking...
fucking good?
Go back here?
What's around here?
Nothing here!
Nothing here, guys!
What?
Oh, I didn't finish the die of that!
Whoops!
I didn't...
I got too excited!
Baby!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Congrats on defeating Swordsnake!
I got gifted a Doki high case for my birthday!
May I have a happy birthday, please?
Oh my god!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear koala!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
I hope you enjoy your high case!
Shines all the more.
I always was an admirer.
Oh, nice.
Alright, now we go back.
I have a great birthday!
Okay, oh, there he is.
Oh, look at him.
Oh, it's just a face now!
Oh, she's crying at his head!
Oh, you...
Eh!
Allow me some time.
Our Lord's carcass is vast.
And not easily...
Are you like eating his head?
Dear Rikard, please...
Find purchase within me.
Oh my god, she's not...
I wish to be your servant.
Your family.
Together.
Let us devour the gods.
Oh, you ate half his head already?
What?
Jesus!
How hungry were you?
So hungry.
She was...
She was so hungry, guys.
Dear Rikard, please...
Find purchase within me.
I wish to be your serpent.
Your family.
Do I kill her now?
Let us devour the gods together.
Wait, I have to kill her?
Why?
Cause she's weird?
Guys.
We can't just kill every weird person in this world.
Then they can't be VTuber.
Alright.
Oh.
Okay.
Bye.
Oh shit!
What?
Ah!
You fuckers!
You are me?
Oh my god!
Okay, die.
You fuckers.
You actual fuckers.
Oh my god!
You ...
Boowo.
Oh my god!
You bated me!
You fuckers bated me!
Oh my god.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
I thought it was... Can I leave?
Oh, no.
Where's the grays?
Wait.
Maybe.
I see the tunnel.
Oh, my God.
I can leave.
Get... Wait.
Oh, my God.
There's a grays right here.
You didn't get me.
You thought you got me.
You thought you got me there.
That's a grays.
I love it.
Fight.
Wait.
I think he's gone forever.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
She's gone.
I bravely ran away.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I don't know if I can kill him.
Okay.
And then she bravely...
No!
I just grabbed my roots back.
Bravely what?
Doki?
Bravely...
She bravely died.
What?
Bravely what?
Okay, we'll do one more.
We'll do one more.
Let's see.
Hit.
Ah!
Sad.
Alright, we get out of here.
We leave now.
Okay, we grab our runes and we bravely run away.
We bravely run away.
Let's just grab this and then...
Goodbye.
Legend of brave Doki.
Alright.
I don't know where to go now.
Just go here.
No?
No, I think... you know what?
That's a story boss, right?
Was he a story boss, guys?
Where the fuck am I, actually?
Oh my god.
Where did I go?
It was... alright, we caught it there.
Okay, this is a good time to call it.
We did it.
We finally finished our beach episode.
What?
Come on.
Come on for y'all.
Huh?
I don't know why he's barking.
But...
But we're gonna...
We're gonna...
We're gonna call it here.
We...
I don't know why he's barking.
Uh... I don't know...
Okay, he's optional.
He's a story boss in my...
In my heart!
He was a story boss!
Oh, and then he walked away.
He's like, oh shit.
She's mad.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
Um...
I have a lot of work to do today.
And also, tomorrow.
And also, uh...
All the days before my actual birthday stream.
But anyway, guys.
I hope you guys...
All...
Had a great time watching.
It was a very long filler episode.
Today and...
Two days ago.
But...
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
I'm glad we fixed the stutter issue.
I wish I fixed it earlier.
I wish I...
I...
Did the fix...
Like, the newest fix earlier.
But like, I hope the studies weren't too bad.
Uh...
During this playthrough.
But now it's...
Now we don't get any.
So that's good.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye!